you
flash where those rest of our squad sir
we wanted to say they after we jump the
DZ got not off course they could be
anywhere
so five klicks from here great so let's
talk with you - good to see you too sir
I think still work yes sir about the
Falls I was fine all right radio HQ
y'all we're gonna take out this flak
cannon and then proceed on with the
mission
yes sir till - three days - over no
jitteriness agent go ahead we've
encountered by Kenneth we're gonna
proceed to take it out before we
continue on with the rest of the mission
confirm over co-teacher you out your
seat
Roger that we're gonna proceed on with
the rest of the mission after we take
off this cannon out
HQ confirm I'm gonna take out that flak
cannon before proceeding on with the SS
squad and the rest of the mission you
can't take out that entire squad
ourselves exactly we need to regroup the
rest of our men after we take out this
cannon it's gonna be hard enough with
just three of us get it
you got any satchel charges one sir all
right perfect
Ewan Horton hold position I'm gonna make
my way up to the cannon when I give the
signal I want you to lay down fire in
their position Suz are all down quickly
group on me understood yes sir all right
stay low
okay
you
when she said to time before we got
fifty seconds
I don't think
sir we have 15 seconds we have got to go
for it get radial it's blue
sir we have a take to the southwest for
position
so LG josef kostan dancing Rossi
see I'm not requesting a fight
jeolban trisomy Newton are finan hit the
rock fall behind
Jasser supports
Lucinda hand increase her Fagin in here
and long cell
officer TURN RIGHT see deeper structure
and comment yes sir that's enough
ah
filter don't
okay
perhaps we should remind him as the
tears of deeds still living are you
gonna light that he just gonna keep
clicking that thing till the enemy hear
this my son turns three next week what's
his name fits you like father like son I
mean I haven't even seen my son
what do you buy a three-year-old
I remember my boys third birthday I
bought him a big red fire truck they had
one of those tall white ladders the
doors open
hell even the lights flash - yeah what
do I do when he turns four or five how
do I bomb with a ten year old that
doesn't even know who I am
up ahead looks like a small town on the
left there's a Shack take a close look
you see that marking sir you think
that's our squad you see up ahead that's
what I'm thinking
place looks empty though they could
clearly place out if that's even them
where the bytes sir port has a point
that's our squat civil our units in
there they've done clear to place out
makes sense okay
stay low and be cautious it's time to
refocus see Tony
Johnson Matthews layoffs he's been
through a lot
he's lucky to be alive he could end up
like Jones or Anderson we don't know
that sack sir they could still be alive
sir how'd you find us we saw the
insignia on the outside of the building
what the hell's going on here with all
due respect sir we're Princeton's of war
this is heavily guarded German outpost
how'd you get in German outpost yes sir
ran by the SS have you seen the officer
the target yes sir we all have a couple
hours ago three of us tried to escape
Jones and Anderson didn't make it out
the officer seemed to get the best of
them
it's just to Johnson you said Johnson
what the hell they do to you tried
everything to get dirt on there there's
no talking to all right we don't have
time for this [ __ ] we cannot stay here
here take my sidearm okay tell me you
guys have another pistol here take this
seriously
let's clear out
we can't just leave him here like that
look we all know he's an oak dition fire
let's move
these are sniffing
should just let word
take cover hold position sir
new allies have been extremely
persistent in trying to kill me I
commend their efforts are a must admit
Xia what a considerable amount of stress
on her I was man supposed to lead his
troops but he is always worried about
being shut ins inside himself I'm of the
opinion sedate ones for this is enough
to make a man go crazy
do you agree but I assure you my name's
Robert seal I will take a moment to
myself got my paper enjoy smoke and
enjoy a moment of relaxation for the
first time in a very very long time
start he make me feel better already
you really are goodness
you
you
you